[Music]
HIV is the human immunodeficiency virus
if you have HIV you have an infection
that damages your immune system over
time and causes AIDS aids stands for
acquired immunodeficiency syndrome it is
the final stage of an HIV infection when
your immune system is damaged and too
weak to fight off ordinary infections
when foreign invaders such as bacteria
and viruses get into your body they can
cause infections these events activate
your body's defenses the white blood
cells of your immune system are part of
your body's defenses one type of white
blood cell called helper T lymphocytes
or helper T cells strengthen your immune
systems response to infection in two
ways first helper T cells release
chemicals that attract other white blood
cells to the site of the infection these
additional white blood cells attack the
invading bacteria or virus
as well as other infected cells second
helper T cells release chemicals that
cause other white blood cells to
multiply these new white blood cells
create markers called antibodies which
can identify the same foreign invader
throughout your body antibodies attach
to the bacteria or virus marking them as
targets for your immune system to
destroy them if you have HIV it travels
through your blood and other body fluids
to infect and kill certain white blood
cells the virus enters helper T cells
which are the primary target once inside
the virus makes many copies of itself as
these virus particles are made they
leave the damaged helper t-cell to
infect other cells the T cell loses its
ability to protect the body from the
ongoing infection and dies in this way
HIV spreads and kills more of your
helper T cells weakening your immune
system as a result other types of
infections are able to take advantage of
your body's inability to defend itself
these infections are called
opportunistic infections if you have an
HIV infection and one or more
opportunistic infections you have AIDS
some of the common AIDS related
opportunistic infections are
inflammation of the tissues covering
your brain and spinal cord called
meningitis inflammation of your brain
called encephalitis respiratory
illnesses such as pneumonia and
tuberculosis intestinal illnesses such
as chronic diarrhea caused by infectious
parasites and cancers such as Kaposi's
sarcoma and non-hodgkin lymphoma
HIV passes from person to person through
infected body fluids HIV can enter your
body during unprotected sex while
sharing drug injection needles during
your own childbirth while breastfeeding
from your mother or from contaminated
blood or blood products although there
is no cure for HIV drugs called
antiretroviral medications can reduce
the amount of HIV in your body one class
of antiretroviral medication called
entry or fusion inhibitors disrupts the
HIV infection process by preventing the
virus from attaching to your cells other
classes of antiretroviral medications
include reverse transcriptase inhibitors
protease inhibitors and integrase
inhibitors these drugs prevent the
creation assembly and spread of new
viruses your doctor may prescribe a
combination of these drug classes known
as highly active antiretroviral therapy
or heart antiretroviral medication
doesn't completely remove HIV from your
body but slows it down enough to enable
your immune system to fight infections
regular blood tests will let your doctor
know how effective your antiretroviral
medication is in controlling HIV if the
number of helper T cells is high enough
in your blood sample your medication is
working treatments for the opportunistic
infections of AIDS are medications
specific for each type of infection for
example your doctor may prescribe
antibiotics if you have pneumonia or
tuberculosis
to avoid getting or spreading an HIV
infection know your HIV status and your
partner status by getting tested
regularly the most effective way to
prevent HIV infection is to avoid
vaginal and anal sex when engaging in
sexual activity you will be less likely
to contract HIV if you only have sex
with one uninfected partner or use latex
condoms for protection avoid using
injectable illegal drugs or sharing drug
needles because the needles may have the
virus on them avoid intoxication from
drugs or alcohol because you will be
more likely to engage in unsafe sexual
behavior